i'm excited to check out this trailer
for denver the news
dune especially because when we step
outside in california right now
it looks like blade runner 2049. i know
this is based on a beloved book i know
it's based on an especially beloved
david
lynch movie it's terrific
there's a crusade coming
do you often dream things that happen
just as you dream them
goddess i wish i could do my hair like
his it's impossible
the test is simple remove your hand from
the box
and you die launching unbox what's in
the box
have proven you can rule yourself
now you must learn to rule others
something
none of your ancestors learned that
looks straight out of rise of skywalker
he's
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
an animal caught in a trap one more of
his own leg
to escape what do you do
looks so weird without a beer
dude's in one of the ip-man movies
beyonce
fierce the mind
oh
[Music]
this dude just opposes annie with
visuals wow
beautiful yeah that looks beautiful it
does indeed
does it say eli roth had a writing
credit i hope so
yeah i want his humor he came in and did
a punch-up
to make it more fun yeah it looks
fantastic that looks that looks
fantastic it's funny that denny
villeneux doing this because
when he picked up for blade runner 2049
i thought he'd be a perfect director i'm
not a big fan of the original blade
runner yet i
associate some of his style that's a
little bit of kin
to ridley scott with this one i was like
his style there's some
mood and ambiance and tone that can
remind me of david lynch
qualities yeah editing this back i
realized i didn't finish my point i felt
that denise villanue
uh improved upon blade runner blade
runner 2049
while his style is similar to really
scots in some ways and while i feel like
there's
parts of his style that remind me of
david lynch's i feel like this will be
a much better adaptation than what david
lynch provided that
original david lynch one that's a film
he practically disowns
yeah it's not a good movie it's not i
only watched about an hour and 10
minutes of it last week
i was like i can't do this i can't sit
through this anymore
this is rough and then i turned it off
and i was like oh this is like a
terribly received film i didn't realize
it was this like
really bad like panned movie and that he
disowned it
i was like yeah okay thank god i don't
feel bad for turning this off now there
are multiple cuts of david lynch is
doing some have alan smithy on the
director credits some have a totally
different
writing credit even though he wrote it
and it's funny because
to look at this trailer and to look at
that movie like most of
the events are here like there's a lot
that is
similar and the same but yeah this movie
looks like it's gonna have a lot more of
a cohesive mood
and a tone because the biggest problem
in the immortal words of jason dolan our
buddy
dune is a movie that you perhaps
appreciate but it just doesn't have like
a pace or a tone really that can grab
you and this looks like denis villeneuve
is going to really bring
that essence because it's not you know
like a tech future so much as it is
about like societies and things like
that
well i heard the 84 film is not that
faithful to the book
or i heard that they like borrow a lot
of elements but they change a lot there
and then here i
heard that denise is aiming to
make this a two-parter if i'm not
mistaken to like really
complete the movie that that's supposed
to be a couple of films
i imagine that with this first
installment that they're planning to set
out to make it
oh this will still feel like a complete
movie on its own but to really
finalize the story you would need a
two-parter that's what i believe that
they're going for from what we're
getting
in terms of what we know from the knees
past work and then seeing it here
i'm loving the atmosphere i'm loving the
overall
tone and the visual effects department
like that's one thing with the david
lynch film that i did like was the
production design
and the makeup that was all great here
like he really
has mastered the art of how to capture
visual effects from a rival to blade
runner and out of here it's
solid solid work you know he's like
reuniting with a couple of players here
josh brolin and dave bautista dave
batissa and oscar isaac can't seem to
escape space movies
or sci-fi movies that shot of
oscar isaac that was circulating the web
looks like poe damer in it like an older
version an older version than ryze
skywalker that's what it looks like
bitter after the events of that movie
and i can't help but think like when you
see zendaya and timothy chalamet because
of their age groups and because of what
timothy chalamet looks like
i i do think of tom holland and zendaya
whenever i see them in the same shot
together
yeah for sure timothy sham is an amazing
actor the dune
fan base for the novel is very hardcore
oh yeah i'm really under the impression
that denise aiming to really honor
the book and honor to satisfy that fan
base if
anything yet knowing the kind of
director he is so he'll take an artistic
freedom
here or there well i have to imagine
because like judging by a rival that's a
sci-fi movie that has a lot on its mind
and it's about communication
and it's very theoretical and it's not
as much engrossed in
technology and cool action and stuff and
i feel like that's the best thing going
for this movie because
there's a lot of cool stuff about dune
there mind altering drugs and
crazy planets with all their different
designs but it's really
from what i gather the book is more
about societies of the future
and it's about ecology and things like
that that are more theoretical and
thematic and i hope that denis
villeneuve can bring
that i think this is going to have the
same
issue that blade runner 2049 had where
that trailer
sort of marketed as a very like
action-backed
cool sci-fi epic if you're familiar at
all with like what you're talking about
thematically this is more of a heady
sci-fi film
with a lot on its mind thematic
explorations
while i'm sure there's gonna be some
cool action to be had like it makes
sense why you get jason momoa for a
certain character and then they're
showcasing all these action scenes which
i'm sure will be cool
oh there's definitely war and stuff yeah
and i mean you know the story of paula
tradies is a bit of an origin tale
anyway
so yeah i'm just saying that i think
people will be like oh there's a lot
more heady than i
anticipated it to be yeah you're gonna
have to wait a while before your worm
battle
i mean that's the thing with all of
denise like uh not all but like
his sci-fi films arrival and bladerunner
and foreign both had those kind of
marketings
where it was like oh is gonna be that
crazy action
then you're watching it it's not you
know no you gotta learn it's language
from the sequences that you get here
especially like what jason memo or the
training sequence that you get with josh
brolin and timothy chalamet you know
there's gonna be some cool action and
some cool visual effects to be behold
here i'm just excited that
i feel like he'll probably knock it out
of the i'm like 99
confident he's gonna knock it out of the
park and give us a dune movie worthy of
the novel
he's that i haven't read he's that guy
now where if i hear he's making
something and especially something
that's difficult to make i'm like ah
until he really screws something up he's
got it
yeah i'm not worried of course and that
quote no because they've released a
trailer teaser yesterday
i must not fear fear is the mind killer
i think making that a big part of the
theme for this movie
is gonna be a really great thing for him
to capitalize on
you know especially for something that
deals so much with like superhuman level
of thought
yeah we're going to talk about the spice
in here well it's funny about this one
is that even though it's an official
trailer
it's a three-minute trailer it feels
like an official trailer yet it
also simultaneously feels like a teaser
trailer but yeah cause all you really
get is the world
and a taste of the steaks yeah pink
floyd
alejandro hodorowski would be proud yeah
this looks great and this looks amazing
i can't i think uh i think it's gonna be
awesome
all right guys what'd you see the dunes
obviously did what do you think of the
dune trailer
leave your thoughts down below do you
think it's going to be better than the
lynch adaptation i feel like all of us
are going to be
feeling that way i think david lynch
feels tired are you such a purist that
you're like don't even try just read the
book
um i'm not going to anytime soon maybe
i'll put it on an audio book
space that over the course of six months
10 minutes a day
no incremental progress is good all
right guys so you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell last but not least let's do a pic
bradley bledsoe bradley uh surprised us
over the weekend with something
beautiful was not expecting this and i'm
very grateful for it he surprised us
with a brand new banner and the second
we got it i was like this is it
this is the banner right here been
wanting a new banner he knocked it out
of the park he nailed it
please follow this guy on youtube
sketchy studios is the name of his
channel i watched this
beautiful essay he did on joker recently
watched his bill and ted
face the music video this guy has a
great youtube channel he's a wonderful
editor he does some experimental content
as well he's a really funny guy
loyal as hell and a musician go check
out bradley love
star on the spotify wherever you get
your music exactly
groove along thank you so much bradley
for being you love the hell out of the
new banner
much love to you brother
[Music]
you